camera that is on your phone right now
is a better camera than Hollywood was
using 20 years ago the camera is not
your problem the problem is the macro
you're scared to post because you're
worried about what other people think
I'm a purebred entrepreneur for real for
real for real like documented
you can imagine the energy that I had in
my body flying out here from Manhattan
I'm gonna talk to thousands of people
who are in the best market during the
most scaled free attention platform in
the history of marketing and yet 98 of
the people in this room won't actually
do anything about it this is what's
called a conundrum
but this can be awesome this new
overrated underrated concept I love this
I'm gonna do it overrated underrated
here we go mocktails underrated huge
business
Formula One properly rated the hype of
Netflix got it crazy so now it's proper
Fresco tray underrated super rapper he's
coming I'm telling you kelp noodles
wildly underrated you want to keep those
carbs down and those calories kelp St
Patrick's Day overrated for some because
they get cocked underrated for other
Seltzer spiked very very overrated it's
just over Indianapolis about to be
massively underrated vcons coming you
heard vlogging Dustin does it you can't
see him oh actually he didn't see him
vlogging underrated March Madness wildly
underrated because I'm going to win the
office pool this year I haven't won in
13 years but I will in burnt Island
wildly underrated if you don't
understand what's going on with be
friends you're lost
I can't believe I did that so well
because the switches are tough but uh
like if I keep it within that for a
second or two I think it's gonna work
[Music]
for pedestrians
you don't look at internet culture and
think oh my gosh yikes I think what's
important is to understand what are we
demonizing and what are we scared of so
to me privacy is controllable if
somebody's listening right now and
they're like no way Gary you're so wrong
I'm like delete the apps the world has
fallen in love with pointing fingers
it's your portal your media it's my
fault I'm social media why are we not
into thumbs how do you stay motivated in
a landscape that's that's yelling at you
until and pointing fingers because I
have no attachment to the validation and
or the tearing down see one of the great
things when you don't believe in your
own headlines is you don't believe in
the trolling either when you were
actually in a state of doing things for
yourself not the addiction of the
validation of the likes or the treachery
of being torn down you're in a much
better place I'm motivated because I'm
detached a stoic Alliance I don't know
if I believe you that you're detached
well I think that's only because you
don't know me which I respect it's one
of the reasons I judge no one I don't
know them garyvee want to talk to you so
much fun thanks for taking the time
thank you I am fascinated by how people
respond to when I talk about
accountability it's poking and so people
don't want it yet it's everything it
will do so much for people but it gets a
little bit longer sometimes shut
everybody so I'd Rather Be Lonely with
myself and accountability than to have
people around me that are pushing
non-accountability having Circles of
energy that are pushing
non-accountability all those friends the
media your feed who are pushing blame
and envy and jealousy I'd rather be by
myself and accountability
a Serial entrepreneur five times New
York Times best selling offer with your
hands together
the number one way to grow anything when
it comes to business is being the best
at understanding where the underpriced
attention of the world is I've had more
people ask me about Gary should I list
homes on the metaverse then I've had
people figuring out how to make perfect
content on YouTube shorts we are
obsessed with tomorrow we are romantic
about yesterday and most everyone does
not execute in today my obsession of
this keynote and this q a is to get the
majority of this room very focused on
today thank you very much Gary good big
round of applause to Cecilia she's going
to be here with the Q a with Gary with
everyone already doing so much videos
and there's just so many similar videos
going out how would you do it to be more
creative and not follow Trends to stand
out why don't you just follow Trends
because I don't want to copy I think a
lot of Agents here feel the same way so
let me understand because you don't want
to copy you're just going to let
everybody else get the business
yeah true
okay I have a better idea why don't you
copy and get some of the business but
how would you stand out you are already
standing out because you're a different
human being you might say one word
differently you might have one different
joke all of us are different you could
talk about your history again you can
control your privacy or not but good
news you're already different because
you're just a different human being
you're also going to have a listing that
somebody else doesn't have that already
Makes You Different the house is
different don't worry about that part
it's it's one of those silly things that
doesn't mean anything
[Applause]
yeah the Q a is always the best because
when you're getting q a you can get the
back and forth and like well then you
know what they're curious about
that with me
[Music]
the energy output of the last 36 hours
is like a lot yeah I think that was the
big theme on stage today like don't
worry about what a people's opinion
don't worry about the content being
perfect just do it the reason people are
not posting is they're insecure we've
got to figure that out most of all you
need to be detached to the positives and
the negatives so that you can actually
do unfortunately most people are so
hungry for the affirmation it makes them
vulnerable for the destruction we need
to think about how to create more mental
Frameworks that don't value the love and
don't value the hate which allows them
to be happy Gary such a pleasure to have
you and all that experts thank you and I
hope to see you soon hope so
[Music]
when I tell you I felt it I was like
that's 100 going in plus I need a
million views on tick tock
I'm so pumped about that
you've been gifted with the evil Voodoo
got me coming back for more even when
I've been screwed dolls full of pins
pierce my heart straight through okay
do's and don'ts and culture dues talk
about things that you care about and
you're passionate about and you know
don't try to jump on trends that you
don't care about but you're doing it
because it seemingly as a trend do's and
don'ts in the workplace do deploy kind
Candor but also deploy A system that
eliminates cancerous individuals don't
don't look the under the way when
somebody's contributing to your bottom
line but they're destroying your culture
do's and don'ts when it comes to social
media dues really learn it and do it
yourself until you really understand it
don't don't Outsource it to your 17 year
old niece because she's 17. very very
touched thank you so much for being on
the show thanks Mom
what excites me about the future is
what's always excited me about the human
race which is the human spirit always
wins in the end we have withstood so
many challenges prior to what we're
dealing with now I've complete and utter
confidence in our capacity to be able to
handle the environmental issues it could
be humanitarian issues and all the other
issues the thing that keeps me
optimistic is history always tells you
the future and humans always win
thank you
someone struck by Cupid